[Música]
Bienvenidos a Francia enfoco su programa
sobre la actualidad francesa en esta
edición hablaremos de la Reforma
pensional propuesta por el gobierno de
Manuel ama un tema candente actualmente
aquí en Francia que ha suscitado
protestas masivas en todo el país
veremos en detalle En qué consiste esta
reforma y a quienes impacta y luego en
un segundo momento veremos ya en detalle
Cómo afecta a quienes por ejemplo
comenzaron a trabajar desde muy jóvenes
y también a quienes ejercen trabajos
duros por último en medio de este pulso
entre el gobierno y los sindicatos
veremos el caso de los jubilados miles
de ellos que se ven abocados a seguir
trabajando
en su programa de gobierno Emmanuel
macan quería aumentar la edad pensional
de 62 a 65 años finalmente pasará a 64
según el texto de ley aprobado en
consejo de ministros esto significa que
para algunas generaciones habrá que
trabajar por más tiempo hasta por 43
años si quieren obtener una pensión
completa
[Música]
el gobierno decidió pasar la edad legal
de jubilación de los 62 a los 64 años a
partir de 2030 en esta fábrica de
cuchillos en la sangre los 40
asalariados se verán afectados por este
cambio para este empleado que nació en
1989 Este cambio es una mala noticia
para mí es muy tarde si uno tiene ganas
de hacer algún tipo de proyecto para
poder disfrutar de la vida Simplemente
es un poco complicado
perdemos dos años en los que uno podría
descansar aprovechar de su familia
disfrutar la vida otros asalariados
todavía no logran proyectarse en el
tiempo
hoy me dicen dos años más y en lo
absoluto No me molesta pero estamos
hablando de algo dentro de 23 años y ahí
sí no sé si de aquí a 23 años querré
trabajar dos años más Aunque para
algunos la pensión todavía está lejos
otros esperan jubilarse pronto y solo
podrán parar mucho Después la edad de
jubilación aumenta de 3 meses por año
Por ejemplo si usted nació en 1964 se
podrá jubilar con una pensión completa a
los 63 años la generación de 1968 será
la primera que tenga que trabajar a los
64 años en esta empresa de calderería El
ruido y la carga de piezas de metal son
lo cotidiano este obrero nació en 1963
hizo los cálculos y para poderse
pensionar con una jubilación plena
tendrá que trabajar nueve meses más se
vuelve a postergar una vez más cuando
uno ya estaba prácticamente al final
tenemos un oficio que no es fácil así
que no sea los 63 años y medio en qué
estado estaré
además de la edad legal el gobierno
acelera también el tiempo de cotización
de un trimestre cada año así para una
pensión plena habrá que cotizar 43 años
a partir de 2027
este impulso reformista ha llevado a que
miles de franceses salgan a las calles
para protestar contra una reforma que
consideran penalizará a los trabajadores
pero para el gobierno se trata de un
progreso en cuanto a cómo se tiene en
cuenta la penosidad del trabajo que
afecta la salud de los obreros veamos el
siguiente reportaje
levantar materiales de varios kilos de
rodillas calibrar máquinas en un ruido
continuo esta habilidad en el trabajo
será mejor tenida en cuenta con la nueva
reforma pensional
tiene 65 años y en esta galería fabrica
uno de sus últimos pasamanos de escalera
se pensiona dentro de tres meses y dice
sentirse aliviado
me va a hacer bien era tiempo ya hay que
parara la fatiga la fatiga a sus 38 años
tendrá que trabajar dos años más y esto
no cae bien
entre el frío en el invierno y el calor
en el verano Además del ruido y los
gases que se pueden respirar por ejemplo
y otros productos para la salud Estoy
seguro que eso a término no es muy sano
tener en cuenta el trabajo duro es uno
de los ejes más importantes de la
Reforma pensional con algunos cambios o
avances la cuenta profesional de
prevención será aligerada en el trabajo
nocturno se daría paso a paso a término
a más derechos 60.000 personas
suplementarias recibirían el beneficio
según el gobierno para los otros
criterios como cargas pesadas posturas
difíciles y vibraciones ninguna se
reconoce oficialmente como trabajo duro
pero se crea un fondo de mil millones de
euros para financiar las acciones de
prevención y de reconversión este
sindicato denuncia una falta de
transparencia estos criterios estarán en
la mano de las diferentes ramas lo que
quiere decir que están en manos de las
empresas y las personas que tienen un
trabajo duro en una empresa o en otra o
van a ser tratados de la misma manera el
día de mañana
Sin embargo los empresarios la reforma
ofrecería un mejor manejo si en realidad
hay algún problema de salud relacionado
con el trabajo entonces hay recorridos
específicos para que el asalariado pueda
jubilarse antes de tiempo o para que
pueda cambiar de trabajo o aligerar el
puesto de trabajo el proyecto de reforma
debe ser votado por el parlamento el 26
de Marzo
la primera ministra Elizabeth fue la
encargada de presentar el proyecto de
ley a los franceses un proyecto que ella
defiende A capa y espada y que considera
además justo sin embargo no todos lo ven
así en especial aquellas personas que
comenzaron a trabajar desde muy temprana
edad porque ellos ya no podrán jubilarse
antes de los 60 años tendrán que esperar
a cumplir 62 sin embargo hay una misma
regla para todo el mundo y es que nadie
estará obligado a trabajar por más de 44
años
ha trabajado desde sus 18 años hoy es
techador y dobla planchas de zinc que
serán utilizadas como canaletas acaba de
enterarse de que con la nueva reforma
pensional se jubilará más tarde de lo
previsto y que tendrá que cambiar sus
planes
debería haber parado a los 60 con la
reforma anterior tuve que cotizar más
tiempo un año y un trimestre más ahora
me doy cuenta de que los 61,3 años se
convertirán en 62 años
Joseph tendrá que trabajar nueve meses
más es una noticia difícil de asimilar
para nosotros ya está es así pero es
para quienes vienen después nosotros Ya
dimos Bueno hoy me doy cuenta de que
seguimos dando un poco la decepciones
casi mayor ahora Joseph foché empezó a
trabajar antes de los 20 años Así que
puede acceder a la jubilación anticipada
este el caso de uno de cada cinco
jubilados en la actualidad a partir de
ahora la fecha en que dejen de trabajar
dependerá de tres casos los que
empezaron a trabajar antes de los 16
años Se jubilarán a los 58 aquellos que
empezaron antes de los 18 lo harán a los
60 La Única condición para ambos casos
es saber cotizado durante 44 años por
último para quienes hayan empezado a
trabajar antes de los 20 años la
jubilación se fijará a los 62 años Sí y
solo si han cotizado durante 43 años y
tres meses por último la reforma
introduce una nueva ayuda para las
mujeres que empezaron a trabajar a una
edad temprana el reconocimiento de su
permiso parental hasta cuatro trimestres
adicionales podrán ser incluidos a la
hora de realizar el cálculo de
suspensiones sin embargo son cada vez
más las personas jubiladas que continúan
con una actividad laboral para poder
mantenerse a flote en su economía mes
tras mes se estima que en Francia hay
unas mil personas en esta situación
veamos el caso de Bruno y Brigitte Bruno
Orlando es un apasionado de los vinos y
el champán tiene 76 años y aunque se
jubiló no ha dejado de trabajar
hoy trabaja como impulsador comercial
independiente en cavas y allí hace
promoción de algunos vinos
es femenino diría yo se lo dije la
estaba esperando se parece a mí
una reconversión para este antiguo
obrero que fue indispensable después de
haber trabajado demasiado
estuve muy enfermo a los 20 años Eso
quiere decir estar en hospitales tuvo un
poco de tuberculosis y también una
crisis de asma muy violenta lo cual me
llevó desgraciadamente la situación de
desempleo y de estar ausente y por eso
Efectivamente es una pequeña pensión lo
que recibo
una pequeña pensión de 800 euros con
este trabajo recibe más o menos unos
1300 euros netos por mes como él son
cada vez más los adultos mayores por lo
general solteros y con buen estado de
salud quienes quieren buscar sentirse
útil en caen es el caso de esta
pensionada que recibe pago de las
farmacéuticas en en casa realiza tareas
administrativas vive sola y dice
trabajar para poder mantener una
actividad y manejar también los
imprevistos
tengo muchos gastos como la mayoría de
la gente el carro las obras en el
edificio cambiar la ducha en la bañera
gastos que no digo que sean ordinarios
Pero bueno que son mucho más que mi
pensión lo que le preocupa también es el
problema de la dependencia a futuro
voy a hacer todo para no tener que ir a
un ancianato Pero bueno si me toca ir
iré no tengo otra opción
es que puede pagar por eso ahora no no
no no no no mi preocupación Es que mi
hijo tenga que ayudarme y eso no lo
quiero
también hace el aseo en casas
particulares con su pensión y todos
estos salarios logra acumular 2.000
euros cada mes vale observa desde hace
14 años el mercado laboral de los
jubilados dirige un sitio de internet
que empareja ofertas de empleo y
candidatos se encuentran desde pequeños
arreglos a servicios personas son ayudas
sencillas Como por ejemplo el realizar
una comida tenemos algunos hombres pero
en su mayoría son mujeres y las mujeres
de Esta generación dejaron sus trabajos
para encargarse de sus hijos tuvieron
carreras entrecortadas y por eso tienen
también pensiones mínimas además de esto
si se separaron de su cónyuge y viven
solas con esa pequeña pensión es aún más
difícil hoy Prácticamente la mitad de
los candidatos inscritos tienen más de
65 años entonces eso es una señal es un
marcador
400.000 pensionados tienen una actividad
remunerada para mantenerse en forma pues
camina por los senderos alrededor de
caen es una carrera contra el tiempo que
pasa con la esperanza de conservar el
mismo equilibrio por el mayor tiempo
posible hasta aquí esta edición de
Francia enfoco Gracias por habernos
acompañado continúen con nuestra
programación en France 24 y France
24.com